For a sexy dinner date, turn up the volume with your look.
Let your eyes do all the talking.
Start out with the taupe eye shadow color...
...and add this on your lids to neutralize your eyes.
Next step: select this vanilla shade and cover your entire lids with this color.
Select the taupe eye shadow color again...
...and use this to contour your lids to add more definition to your eyes.
Now with the matte dark cocoa bean color, use this to line your eyes.
You wanna make little dash marks and connect the lines together...
...to create one continuous line.
Select the darkest color in your palette...
...and start around the outer third of your eyes,...
...build up the intensity to create the sexy smoldering shape.
Take this antique silver eye shadow color...
...and use it to highlight the inner corners of your eyes.
This will help bring more brightness to your eyes.
With the darkest color again, lightly brush this along the lower lash line...
...and then connect with the top lid.
And now, just even out both eyes.